very much guys this is a lot of fun we
have not done this all right
B Happy Thanksgiving with that win first
of all let's talk about the game fourth
quarter frogs take us through your
mindset in that second half and how you
close them out tonight I think great
team win again um obviously a back to
back so want to make sure that we take
take advantage of this home stand and
just take a little bit less I think I
was overthinking a little bit and uh got
great teammates so was a lot of fun Paul
the mindsets changing around here here
you guys never let go of the Rope felt
like you knew you were going to pull
this one out
tonight I I don't got much to say man
this what we've been doing we've been
working our ass off and uh it's so
tonight Cole how about this crowd they
stood for the last 30 minutes here
tonight how much of a lift did they give
you that's spectacular you know they did
their thing shout out to the crowd that
was big time okay now this is a
tradition we haven't done this in eight
years so you three are going to carve
this turkey here tonight all right who's
going to get the knife somebody you're G
to get right in there Paulo BR okay
what's your M take us through this how
you going to
attack
R I don't
know Cole how about you grab a kite grab
a slice grab a slice all
[Music]
right follow get in there hey you can
cut it or you can rip off a leg my think
I don't really eat turkey like that but
it was a good
D all right take us through bad Carol
Thanksgiving tomorrow what are give me
the sides the fixings what are we going
to have we got it all bro pull up and
find out Thanksgiving
2023 good du all right how about you
what's a Cole Anthony Thanksgiving hey
you said to yourself it's a Cole Anthony
Thanksgiving we going to have good
dishes we going to have good vibes it's
going to be a nice little day they might
pull up too yeah got a whole team
environment how about you what's your
favorite side France give me your
favorite side I'm not from here but the
sweet potato casserole thing that you
guys make really good really good ver
for you I got some white ver for you hey
you guys enjoy this that was a heck of a
win great job that's against the
defending champs congratulations guys
appreciate Happy Thanksgiving
guys